so for the viewers who haven't seen this
Gillette advert can you give me the
sargon of akkad
cliff notes on what you think it is or
how you how would you describe it
someone hasn't seen it it's just
feminist propaganda it's it's just 101
and it's so it's so basic I mean it
starts off with the mean to movement and
toxic masculinity so you know you're
dealing with a feminist I mean the
author the the director sorry was some
Kim gay him him Gary yeah she's a famous
feminist director she's who's directed
many controversial some sort Clips like
this that have caused a stir because she
seems to take a one-sided feminist
narrative on the idea that women are
being oppressed by men and men have to
change yeah and I mean the way she was
like the whole thing conflates like boys
roughhousing as children with Harvey
Weinstein's predatory behaviour in
Hollywood and then they have like Terry
Crews who again was assaulted by a
Hollywood executive you know some
powerful Hollywood exec and it's all tie
back as if it was because Harvey
Weinstein play fought with his brother
when he was a kid it's like that's not
the reason yeah you know the reason is
because he's disgusting ugly repulsive
perverts
with absolutely no moral standards he
doesn't represent anyone but Harvey
Weinstein and the goons around him the
Ypres tags you know that's not
reflective of most men and it's
definitely inappropriate so that it is
yeah it's catastrophic thinking it's
absolutely worse isn't it it's bigoted
thinking it it's absolutely worst I mean
you know we we don't just sit there and
go black people look at these crime
rates you're all responsible you know
that would be ridiculously racist so
when they go men look at what Harvey
Weinstein's done you're responsible it's
the same logic so yeah I don't know
during the advert you the bit that
really really got me was this I think
they're a barbecue so there's a bunch of
guys a barbecue doing man things
drinking beer and flipping beef and
stuff like that and there's a couple of
kids play fighting two boys play
fighting and the scene is allowed to
continue then it cuts away and then it
comes back and the suggestion is that
men should step in to stop other men or
stop other males ie boys from play
fighting and
you're right that the implication is
that by allowing boys to play fight you
are fostering this tyrannical misogynist
in Waiting it sounds ridiculous when you
say so anyone who either was a young boy
who knows young boys you know has
children or some it just sounds absurd
you know cuz young boys play fighting is
essentially I looked up a bunch I went
and research this to do the video I did
on it and basically young boys play
fighting is completely normal according
to likely leading psychologists oh yeah
and I mean you know everywhere every man
knows this because when they were a kid
they play fights with their friends too
you know it's it's just like the way men
socialize among themselves and establish
hierarchies you know and like the one of
the one of the studies I was really
looking out was 85% of of boys teenage
boys could tell when a play fight was
going on you know like eighty five
percent of the time they could tell the
fight was going that there was a play
fight because you know they're having
fun but and and this was mostly like 70
percent adults as well like men and
women who had grown up with a brother
but women who'd grown up without a
brother always thought the fights were
serious and so it's like right Cain
there really is a distinction here about
male/female thinking you know and women
who are not used to what young men are
like don't recognize the behavior for
what it is but the thing is the same
with like animals you know you see you
know puppies fighting and stuff like
this you know it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah it's it's it's just natural
you know and so there and they panic
about this excessively and so they kind
of it kind of is a small group of mostly
women who don't really understand men
and are kind of afraid of them that's
how I view modern feminism these days
and so honestly how I view it because
it's - the backlash on this Gillette
adverts been insane the immunity the
YouTube operate and down rate was ten to
one on dislike and then early yeah it
was ten to one and then there was the
views didn't increase by a tremendous
amount I was watching this on a on
YouTube yesterday
these didn't increase by a tremendous
amount and the dislike to like has been
brought back down to around about five
to one and really it was it was two to
one when I saw it the other day
well anything it may have even gone
further but it when it was very very
first went out and that may be due to
just the first adopters of the people
who have taken the most offense so they
you know it could be that could be
realistic but there's a lot of
accusations of a bit of unfair play
going around I I've heard I've seen many
people saying my dislike has been
removed and things like this comments a
lot of comments are being deleted and
yeah and pinned ones are changing have
you also seen I don't know I don't know
how much truths behind this but its
honor there's a lot of websites that are
reporting it have you seen that Kim
Gehrig has actually been accused of
sexual abuse by two men and five women
no I did not know that the I really I
mean I guess we've got to listen and
believe over me yeah well I mean Eve the
victims yeah well yeah definitely so I I
am struggling to find it on anyone who
is super reputable yet I think it's
probably dangerous - um well I will wait
for confirmation yeah exactly
Gillette Miss undressed or is it just
Gillette miss undressed ad was directed
by an accused pedophile
miss Kim Gehrig one of her victims
committed suicide oh my
well I mean we'll wait we'll wait and
find out a little bit more about that
but that yeah no matter what whether
that's the truth or not and even if it's
not the truth it's probably speaks to
just how by part isn't it makes
everything you know I mean like it's
like okay well even if someone's made
that up that right well this is how far
the feminist narrative is tried to push
masculinity oh no I need to come up we
need to we need to come back with
something that's even more outlandish
and ridiculous and you have this
extremist sort of it's it is it is just
an entirely one-sided argument that
they're having and the thing is the only
people on the like like no one no one in
reality thinks that boy boys play
fighting is a particularly harmful
behavior because it's always by consent
you know I mean that you know well I
took my bullying yep see bullying is
something different but like the the
pathologizing of just male behaviors and
then I mean in the average you know when
the dad goes up and says we don't treat
each other that way and say well they
both consent you know me you could see
in the in the clip they're showing you
the two boys have big grins on their
face you know they couldn't have
portrayed it more as boys play fighting
yeah it's an aggressive exactly you know
and so it's not wrong for them to treat
that each other that way because they
both consent to being treated that way
you know they both consent to the sort
of competition of the rough-and-tumble
which is fine I mean you know it's fun
when I was a kid to play fight with my
friends I used to like it you told you
write as well it helps I'm sure if we
had Jordan Pete's in hand I'm sure he'd
be able to tell us exactly why but
exactly yeah I mean I'm waiting for the
commentary from him I imagine will be a
thesis on just how wrong Gillette is in
terms of upbringing of young men you
know give us all the psychological
literature as well and the thing is
although I can't cite it and it's not my
field I've heard him across the content
of consumed of him talking about just
how important this is and how it helps
young boys to be able to learn the
limits of their own strength and you the
proprioception in terms of how your body
moves and how other people's bodies move
and into the game's iterated across time
analogy he uses talking about rats and
he says if one rat play fights with
another rat and then it loses it rolls
over and then the rat allows it to come
back and play again yes and you've got
to let them win 30 percent at the time
roughly to keep them engaged in the game
yeah yeah I want a large or decently I
don't know we go yeah and if I I think I
think that there's some definite
definitely some truth no I know I think
it's very much about socializing boys
because I think that young men are very
powerful this is what this is what I
think I don't say women but a certain
kind of excessively concerned sort of
moral busybody woman is usually like and
I can think of many examples of this
kind of work they're not badly intent
intentioned or anything but I just don't
think they understand and I think that
young minute
may strong they're a powerful force in
the world when they want to be and this
is usually why societies had quite
strict rules for young men you know I
mean like if you go back to the Middle
Ages you know young men would have been
taught how to use a spear and a shield
and a bow and things like this and they
would have had to you know join in and
become part of the local sort of militia
or something like that for the
conviction of some sort yeah there may
well be some kind of conscription
exactly and it's because it's understood
that young men have fighting instincts
you know not all of them all the time
but there is definitely a parts of young
men that is naturally designed to fight
and I mean I watched sure I think this
was it Michael pause hello a few years
ago where he effectively went and like
some kind of underground gang in London
it's like boxing gang a bare-knuckle
boxing gang okay and it was about the
pleasure of fighting because these these
men who did this they didn't take drugs
or drink their drug was fighting itself
the adrenaline kick of it and I think
that like that's what Call of Duty is
tapping into you know that kind of
videogame it's that kind of adrenaline
high from conflict and combat catharsis
almost no no no no not quite that like
not they like I like the fact that
physical competition is also a game you
know it might become like a deadly in a
game in but if there are set rules and
they I mean in a war they're the rules
of who can kill who first you know they
don't have to be rules a conceptual
there might be physical rules but there
are set rules and there's an objective
and both of you going for it and it's
understood that you're on the same terms
like that for the reason it's not murder
for to kill a soldier in a battle you
know it's understood you're both that
fight and I think I think there's a part
of the male psyche that is enjoys that
you know for some men only obviously you
get this or weaker men who don't like
these kind of physical competitions and
I think it's that kind of and then I
guess you'd call it primal if you want
but that kind of urge that the you know
the the shooter genre is tapping into
the kids these days you know and I think
it's wrong to try and deny that aspect
of human nature but obviously the
feminists who have got absolutely no
empathy for men whatsoever
don't even try couldn't possibly
understand it and so all they see is oh
there is a defective woman as christina
hoff sommers puts it and I think she's
writing that don't they do ya I think
what's interesting is the fact that the
scalable and much more effective
strategy for controlling men or ie
making men's behavior more holistic and
more beneficial to society as a whole
would be to remodel it and have have it
almost brought on by desire as opposed
to entrenched and locked in by rules so
if you were if you were able to have it
be desirable for all men to call out
every man that was a rapist immediately
or if you had it as a rule that play
fights were something that was taken
pride in what was done with with honor
and with a sense of decorum etc etc
that's much more scalable and it's much
more difficult because it's enforced by
the group as opposed to choosing a
top-down approach that's a bottom-up
approach right which is - did naturally
by the culture supposed to a top-down
approach which is this it's almost like
trying to litigate authoritarianism it's
here are the rules a group of people who
don't really understand you are gonna
dictate rules for you and now you're
gonna feel these rules are chafing you
know and like so there was a New Zealand
TV series called um seven periods with
mr. Hornsby and it was about this old
Victorian like like like an old British
Empire Army officer had newzealand to
teach a group of kids who were often
like you know a Maori and but not just
Maori units the group of blues group of
boys and I don't know why this thing
resonated with me but there was
something about that I found
unbelievably charming and it was because
of the old-fashioned way that Gorm's be
the teacher treated the boys you know he
he didn't treat them in the way the boys
treated now is it they're not he didn't
scold them for acting like boys you know
there's fictional so she knows it's all
a representation but I think there's
some there's some truth to
that liked the idea of this because like
fruit the way he was the way he would
tell him off is something really
resonated with me it wasn't you should
not do that it was that's enough you
know and so it's you know some of the
boys are fighting or playing around
being rambunctious whatever it wasn't
you know pathologize them and saying
where you're wrong you you you're not
you're doing this because you don't even
realize why and you shouldn't do it
because bad under every circumstance it
was just no the limit you know and so
you know don't it's not innately wrong
to be what you are but it is wrong to go
too far in what you're doing and that's
I think the best way to try and talk to
young men about how to behave frankly if
feminists want to do that and they do
want to do that it's like okay well then
as someone who was a young men has you
know a son and a young man has a son and
might have a bit more quote/unquote
lived experience than your average
feminist in this regard don't tell them
they can't do something just make sure
they are doing it to within a receptacle
parameter yeah you know because then
it's not bad for him to be innately what
they are yeah speaking of chafing there
is a scene in the video where a man is
shaving his legs as well I think isn't
as you seen that I can't remember there
is there's a doozy a he's got it up on
the couch I thinking he's shaving his
face which is you just have to I've got
some friends that are swimmers that
might you know it is it might actually
only be in the UK version and if it is
that's hilarious
the I don't recall that being in the US
it definitely definitely exists I don't
have to watch that imagine imagine for a
second that I have made you the director
of the exact opposite advert so it's
women it's women telling women what
women should do from an from a
completely opposing narrative can you
can you try and run us through the
storyboard of what you think would
happen
well surely what I would want to happen
I think we'd end up with know what you
would what the equivalent would be if
they were to take the exact polar
opposite of what we've got well it'd
have to be something about false rape
allegations wouldn't it
so women false rape allegations begin in
the school you know whether so we'd have
Cavanaugh's trial where he's being
accused falsely by three people who like
recanted their statements and one person
just had absolutely no evidence or no
corroborating witnesses or even the time
or dates when this is when the
accusations are supposed to have
happened it seems that there was nothing
against Cavanaugh and he had
unbelievably reputable female character
witnesses on his side to back him up so
it start with something like that the
the stress of having to go through this
as Cavanaugh and then when we talk that
back so you know it's it's my young girl
I would I'd be pathologizing some kind
of young woman's behavior where she's
getting taken dolls and Dar playing with
dolls were getting you know click you
know smiley get two different boys or
something yeah you know it'd be
something something about a natural
female behavior that you know that um
that I would be trying to I would be
trying to make something that they need
to stop you shouldn't be putting your
makeup on you in the morning you should
be letting your leg hair grow oh well
yeah but whatever it is but the thing is
I don't the reverse should be made
obviously no I obviously it's to
illustrate just how yeah insane it is
and I you know if you were to tell young
girls that they should be less feminine
yeah be awful why I don't know yeah why
would anyone
[Laughter]
[Music]